[Music]
huge response to this last show as I
said and you have spent years and years
writing writing these these stories of
these characters and not knowing what
the reaction would be there's a clip
it's on the internet right now of fans
reacting YouTube video of fans reacting
to what you call the red wedding which
is the most stunning thing many of us
have seen in television maybe ever
certainly in a long long time so let's
take a look now you get to watch real
fans reacting to the sea
you know what that's why this is the
best show all time
I press all of those clips all of those
clips were set up by people who had read
the books 13 years ago and knew it was
coming and wanted their friends and
relatives and loved ones they knew it
was nothing so they got real reactions
they knew that it was coming and they
wanted innocent people to to get the
reactions that's amazing I saw one of
them saying in comment now you know why
your nerdy friends were really depressed
13 years
[Laughter]